oddio se stata la cintura a tutte in
tempo
lotito e libertà resto ci entriamo
vedere le montagne russe più paurose è
più pericolose al mondo ho già paura
perché io ho un sacco di paura delle
montagne russe purtroppo perché mi fanno
paura le altezze e quindi so già che mi
faranno un sacco di paura anche se sono
solo in video
potevi sapere nei commenti se voi siete
coraggiosi riusciti a far le montagne
russe o se mi fanno paura siete bronchi
mettetevi cody lasciate un bel like se
non siete le altre cose poi siamo subito
allora numero uno sono un taglio
risoluto proprio la montagna russa
perché è molto piccola comunque e alla
vegas e coloro che oggi non rimani
coraggio di farlo in pratica e sopra un
edificio altissimo e non è molto grande
perché non è che fai dei loop non fa il
giro della morte però sceglie tutto giù
e che sembra che sta accadendo
dall'edificio quindi penso che sia super
spaventosa fatemi sapere se voi avreste
il coraggio di farlo avreste il coraggio
di farla
musicista lista l'adrenalina solo vorrei
guardate poi quelli davanti a dai
cadendo dura pochissimo però penso che
in quella frazione di secondo te la fai
a boston
eppure il rispetto oggi tra l'altro non
so perché ma quelle quello poltroncine
mi sembrano così poco sicure quella
ragazza si sta ottenendo dietro oddio
ragazza chi sono gli occhi non ce la fa
e nuovo ecco la visuale da davanti non
avrei mai il coraggio di farla purtroppo
massimo quanto è alto quarate sale
veramente in alto e poi fa un giro
quindi non sa neanche quanti toe della
morte però oddio solo il pensiero di
stare così in alto
mi vengono i brividi voi cosa ne pensate
riuscireste a fare questo sicuramente
una bella botta di adrenalina però
vediamo se sia una visuale dall'alto
sennò visualità uno dei passeggeri
vediamo sarà anche degli ascensori
poi nella discesa fa un giro risale
perché tra l'altro la cosa più
spaventosa sono le discese ripide
vediamo torna indietro e poi prende la
rincorsa
ok qua abbiamo un po di giri della morte
sembra che li ha sparati nel cielo anche
questo è altissimo potevi sapere se
anche voi che l'adrenalina solo a
guardare i video come quello che fa
paura e che penso sempre che potrebbe
non funzionare qualcosa non lo so parte
una vite e si smonta oppure non lo so la
cintura si slaccia musotto tra queste
paure
sicuramente però deve essere super
divertente perché per il coraggio di
miseria bar il fai knight si chiama
questa montagna russa e sale ripidissima
sarà un in discesa super ripida nuvole e
minori ma
[Musica]
avreste il coraggio di farlo questo di
tutto il parco dall'alto libri però se
non super divertenti da guardare
comodamente seduti al sicuro sa di
spider man che se non spagnolo visto
perché sono stata in florida universal
studios e c'erano le montagne russe di
hulk
il treno è forse siamo appunto anche
questa di spider man con la divulga era
pazzesca altissima c'era una rete sotto
che ho pensato perché se la reggia sotto
vuol dire che si può cadere perché di
spider man non me la ricordo
vediamo un po come sembra tranquilla
sembra addio dura poco troppo odio
risale ancora tutti io questa salita
terribile terribile solo vederla mi sta
riempendo di adrenalina
wow avreste frase di farla passaggi su
permette finalmente di superman doveva
essere altri alta in tanti la sensazione
che stai volando come superman un'altra
salita fa ancora pro forse questo è meno
alta si sembra meno volta prossimo anche
questo l'ho visto è in crescita rimane
sospeso e se completamente in verticale
quindi non sa neanche una curva così
diciamo sei proprio così in verticale e
molto coraggio per farlo vediamo e poi
parti all'improvviso
velocissimo oddio la cosa che fa paura
anche qualche sembra che la giostra sia
rotta non lo so che si stia collegando
magari hai paura che non si colleghi
bene con l'altro pezzo e non finisci
nella rotaia e cadi per terra oddio
prossima tta un po motivo cosa sta
succedendo www.r super in alto però non
quanto le altre che abbiamo visto finora
gira tutto vediamo se sale ancora in
alto che cosa succede qua o torna
indietro oppure si apre perché si è
fermata oddio sta tornando indietro
masino si rifà di tutto il percorso
all'indietro
ah no è sceso in un altro percorso nato
sto comunque fa meno paura perché quello
che fa più paura sono le altezze quindi
sta sembrava divertente e prossimo a
questa si chiama sling shot quindi
immagino che ti sparano in aria
vediamo anche se l'è già visto qualche
volta e li trovo non so perché mi
sembrano così poco sicuri in pratica se
in una specie di altalena tra virgolette
hai delle corde attaccate e ti sparano
in aria
ovviamente sei protetto e 6 chiuse tutto
però tanta ti sembra proprio di volare
perchè non sei attaccato a niente di
terribile e poi dopo come quindi come
torni a terra ha tra l'altro giri anche
no non mi piace proprio questa voi cosa
ne pensate
sì ma anche questo l'ho vista ed è
inquietantissimo lo stesso se non
sbaglierà las vegas lo stesso e adesso
però un edificio altissimo altissimo
quindi molto più alta delle classiche
montagne russe
proprio perché sopra un edificio e c'è
una specie di braccio
loro stanno seduti lì e in pratica gira
e basta e di rete ma non fa tanto paura
però se tu guardi giù da lì è altissimo
quindi tra l'altro potete che rimangono
un po in obliquo
quindi hai la sensazione penso che stai
per cadere tua
sì decisamente non avremo il coraggio di
fant anche quest voglio avere il
coraggio di fare questo tra l'altro
questa è una delle più paurose di
convivenza voglia di andare un parco
divertimenti adesso a questi aiuta in
realtà virtuale queste gli farebbero
meno paura perché almeno non vedo contro
sono in alto wow
ti stai proprio in orizzontale sono
completamente legati anche i piedi
queste sono tornati non si vede niente
ma in questi quello realtà virtuale
forse questo è un altro non hanno potuto
vedere con la realtà virtuale forse
perché è un po difficile da fermare
effettivamente quindi questo dovrebbe
essere un altro
vediamo conto è alto oddio
ecco inizia la salita qua o e di saw
l'enigmista sarà nello schermo tanto
ecco che sale io
questo barry bideau oddio acqua la
visuale da davanti delle persone
oddio ma si sta farcitura si è staccata
la cintura guardate guardate qua è stata
la cintura o mio dio
[Musica]
ecco poco
guardate oddio si è staccata la sil
turati post era stata nel panico più
totale
penso che sia comunque sicuro non si
apre poverino ha subito preso la cintura
per riallacciare la oti ricorda
l'impatto comunque dovrebbe essere lo
stesso sicuro è una sicurezza in più una
pro dovrebbe essere comunque sicuro non
si dovrebbe aprire appunto in fatto di
sapere qual è quella che mi hanno fatto
più paura di tutte a me quella con il
braccio
che se fuori dal palazzo e gira tutto
intorno secondo me quello sarebbe il più
spaventoso scrivete nei commenti secondo
voi qual è il più spaventoso lasciate
pure il minuto così poi vado a rivederli
ma tanto mi sapere anche se voi avete
mai fatto le montagne russe quali sono
state le più spaventose che avete mai
fatto
raccontatemi qualcosa se è successo
qualcosa di interessante se siete mai
bloccati se è successo qualcosa insomma
scrivete tutto nei commenti e allora
mila sopra 4 castellini si può cliccare
per vedere i nostri altri video cliccate
su quella che preferite e buona visione
ciao